if jenny was blindfolded
she would think that i'm very she and
aggie
about this point
my arm comes out
and i just end up a different shape
and she's blindfolded she didn't know
about the arm coming out there because
all she knows is she has the same
feeling
so she has the same feeling with one and
the other and that's how you start
piling your aikido techniques together
you go oh yeah well that one feels like
that one and that one so you've got to
experience these popping in what called
oh this is the same one as that one
and they painted all the worms the same
so this is how you build your ikea
though when
when they go god it's just too many
techniques to remember
there isn't as long as you
stick to the same format you go here and
she's not falling down oh i know what i
do i'll give her this
that's when they're individual
when you can get them
and bring your arms through and you're
the only person doing it then the only
difference is the arm
that's fine without touching
but that's being caught up in the same
energy
i'm doing i'm doing exactly the same
i'm just doing short footwork
don't do that
um okay so so do it again the women
hanging shoe nagi should be experienced
the same
to them but you're
doing this one hand
you're doing this two hands
there's lots of there's lots of
variations you know you can you can do
this
shoulder
too much
try some sheer naggies try some more
images put put them together and see if
you can make the only difference that
last part of the arm if they're not
falling on the sheer naggy
you shouldn't need their room and aggie
to secure it
okay so that's your goal